Hi guys, my name is Alini.
大家好，我叫阿利妮。
I'm from Brazil and I've been a fan of the show for a few years now.
我来自巴西，这几年我一直是这个节目的粉丝。
I first started watching when I was 16.
我最早是在16岁时开始看的。
It was my senior year of high school and at the time I was having a lot of fear and anxiety because I had no idea what I wanted to do with my life.
那时我正读高中最后一年，当时我有很多恐惧和焦虑，因为我完全不知道自己的人生想要做什么。
I didn't know what profession I wanted or what college and the show really helped me to understand that not only my feelings were valid but also that I could trust myself.
我不知道自己想从事什么职业，也不知道该上什么大学，而这部剧真的帮我认识到，不仅我的感受是合理的，而且我也能相信自己。
and that I should trust the process that eventually things were going to work out.
并且我应该相信这个过程，最终一切都会好起来的。
And now I'm 24.
而现在我24岁了。
I'm a psychologist and I'm studying to get into residency, which has given me a lot of the same viewing reading thoughts that I had back then.
我是一名心理学家，正在备考住院医师，这让我产生了很多和当年一样的思考和感悟。
And rewatching the show because of the podcast is really helping me through it again.
因为这个播客，重温这部剧真的再次帮我度过了那段时期。
So thank you so much.
所以非常感谢你们。
Thanks for the great advice and thanks for always being that show that's there when I need comfort.
感谢你们提供的好建议，也感谢你们一直作为那个在我需要安慰时陪伴在侧的节目。
Welcome, welcome back to How We Made Your Mother.
欢迎，欢迎回到《老爸老妈的浪漫史》。
I'm Josh Radner.
我是乔什·拉德纳。
I am joined by my friend Craig Thomas.
和我一起的是我的朋友克雷格·托马斯。
Hello, Craig.
你好，克雷格。
Hey, Josh.
嘿，乔什。
Very happy to be with you.
很高兴能和你在一起。
co-created a show called How I Met Your Mother with Carter Bayes that ran on CBS from 2005 to 2014.
我和卡特·贝斯共同创作了一部名为《老爸老妈的浪漫史》的剧集，于2005年至2014年在哥伦比亚广播公司播出。
I played Ted Mosby on that show.
我在剧中饰演泰德·莫斯比。
And we are doing a deep dive.
我们正在进行深度剖析。
We're revisiting the show.
我们在重温这部剧。
All these many years later, we are discovering gems.
多年后的今天，我们正在发掘其中的珍宝。
We're discovering things we would have done different.
我们正在发现那些我们本可以做得不同的事情。
We're interrogating the mystery of why people from Brazil and all over the world continue to love this show.
我们在探讨为什么来自巴西和世界各地的人们会继续热爱这部剧的奥秘。
I will say that Ben Lee and I, as Radner and Lee, we toured Brazil in 2017, I think.
我要说的是，本·李和我，也就是“拉德纳与李”组合，大概在2017年去巴西巡演过。
That's so cool.
太酷了。
I don't think I ever, yeah, tell that story.
我想我以前好像，对，讲讲那个故事吧。
It was the first time I really, I really learned that Brazilians love how I met your mother.
那是第一次我真正地、真正地了解到巴西人有多么喜爱《老爸老妈的浪漫史》。
How I met your mother is huge, demonstrably huge in Brazil.
《老爸老妈的浪漫史》在巴西极其受欢迎，这是毋庸置疑的。
We've really heard over the years so many nice things.
这些年来，我们确实听到了太多美好的评价。
And did you feel that love, Josh, when you were touring with Ben through there?
乔什，你和本在那里巡演时，有感受到那种热情吗？
Is that what you're saying?
你是这个意思吗？
Oh my God, yeah.
哦天哪，是的。
It was pretty extraordinary.
简直太非同寻常了。
I mean, our shows were incredibly packed and very, you know, some people weirdly like had, the album hadn't been out that long.
我的意思是，我们的演出座无虚席，而且你知道，奇怪的是有些人，那张专辑发行其实没多久。
People were really singing along.
人们真的跟着一起大合唱。
But I also like, our shows were spoke to a bigger fan base than our band currently had.
但我也觉得，我们的演出吸引了比我们当时的乐队本身要庞大得多的粉丝群体。
And I'm not saying that there weren't some deep Radner and Lee fans, but there were also how I met your mother fans there that were excited to hear the music.
我并不是说没有坚定的“拉德纳与李”的粉丝，但现场也有《老爸老妈的浪漫史》的粉丝，他们很高兴能听到这些音乐。
And it was really fun.
真的非常有趣。
Yeah, it was a great time.
对，那是一段美好的时光。
And, you know, it also, you know, the fact that, that this, the person who wrote the letter is studying to be a psychologist, I think also speaks to this thing of like, for those people who are, you can watch how I met your mother as like, this is just a good laugh, this is a good story.
而且，你知道，写这封信的人正在学习成为一名心理学家，我觉得这也说明了这样一点：对于那些把《老爸老妈的浪漫史》看作是一部能带来欢乐、讲了个好故事的人来说——
But for people who are psychologically minded, I think that the show isn't particularly pleasing and also this podcast, I hope, is particularly pleasing.
但对于有心理学思维的人来说，我认为这部剧格外讨人喜欢，而且我也希望这个播客同样格外讨人喜欢。
We sometimes have guest appearances an actual psychologist on this show.
我们有时会在节目中邀请真正的心理学家作为嘉宾。
I think that the reason, one of the reasons that the show tends to transcend geography and race and ethnicity is because it deals with these sweeping, psychologically universal concepts of how do we get older, how do we let go, how do we forgive, How do we form relationships?
我认为这部剧之所以能够超越地理、种族和国界的原因之一，是因为它探讨了这些宏大且具有心理学普遍性的概念：我们如何变老，如何放手，如何原谅，我们如何建立人际关系？
How do we end relationships?
我们如何结束人际关系？
I mean, these are things that it doesn't matter where you are, who you are.
我的意思是，无论你在哪里，无论你是谁，这些都是你会遇到的问题。
These areas, you'll hit a lot of these areas in your life.
在你的生活中，你会在很多方面经历这些领域。
Yeah, I feel like the show, we hear a lot that it's people's comfort show, but almost paradoxically, I think it's also their take a leap show.
对，我觉得这部剧，我们经常听到它是人们的“慰藉之剧”，但几乎有些矛盾的是，我认为它也是他们的“勇敢一跃之剧”。
She was just talking about two moments where the show helped her take a leap.
她刚才正是在谈论这部剧帮助她勇敢迈出两步的时刻。
And there is that feeling of this is a comfort show, but it's also a show that progresses.
那种感觉是，这既是一部带来慰藉的剧，但同时也是一部不断前行的剧。
It is about time.
是时候了。
It is about evolution.
这是关于进化的。
It is about becoming a perspective.
这是关于形成一种视角。
The way we frame our life, the way we become aware that our life is a story that moves forward and we get to shape that narrative to some extent.
我们构建生活的方式，我们意识到生活是一个不断向前发展的的故事，并且我们在某种程度上可以塑造这个叙事。
I love that part of her message just that she said it helped her in these moments of making a leap.
我非常喜欢她传达的信息中的那一部分，她说这在那些跨越转折的时刻帮助了她。
And the fact that congratulations that you made this leap to this new career, that's wonderful.
事实上，祝贺你勇敢迈出这一步，开启了新的职业生涯，这太棒了。
I'm so glad the show is there for you at time.
我很高兴这个节目能在当时陪伴着你。
It's also interesting to interrogate the idea of a comfort show.
审视“慰藉剧”（comfort show）这个概念也很有意思。
The fact that that how I met your mother, we hear it so much, is comforting to people.
事实上，就像《老爸老妈浪漫史》一样，我们经常听到它能给人们带来安慰。
Doesn't mean that the characters on the show are comfortable all the time.
这并不意味着剧中的角色一直都过得很舒适。
In fact, the characters on the show are in deep discomfort a lot.
事实上，剧中的角色经常处于极度的痛苦之中。
They're mostly uncomfortable.
他们大部分时间都感到很不自在。
他们大多数时候都过得很纠结。
But what I think is comforting about it is that notion of perspective, is that notion of family and community being there alongside of you and knowing that in your discomfort, you, on the other side of that discomfort might be the life you're really longing for.
但我觉得它能带给人安慰的是那种视角观念，是那种家庭和社区就在你身边陪伴的感觉，并且让你知道，在你的痛苦之中，在痛苦的另一端，可能就是你真正渴望的生活。
Yeah, it's not a show of stasis.
对，这不是一部一成不变的剧。
No.
没错。
The comfort of the show is not in stasis.
这部剧带给人的安慰并不在于一成不变。
The comfort of the show, I think, is look at how fucked up all these people are, too, just like how I'm feeling fucked up.
我认为这部剧带给人的安慰在于：看啊，这群人也同样一团糟，就像我现在的感觉一样。
And there's something about the flaws and the vulnerability of these characters that I think is comforting, even though it's a mess in a way, too.
这些角色的缺点和脆弱有一种魔力，我觉得这很抚慰人心，尽管某种程度上这也一团糟。
It's almost like when you get to know someone you're really inspired by that you really think, like, has either a career that's enviable or a family life Or just a person in the world that you look at from afar and go, they've really figured something out.
这有点像当你去了解一个真正让你备受启发的人，你觉得他们拥有令人艳羡的职业生涯，或者美满的家庭生活，或者你只是远远地看着世上的某个人，心想：他们真的是把人生都盘算明白了。
And then you get to know them over a couple meals, and you're like, oh my God, they're just as well as me, like they're just, they have the same boiling insecurities, the same childhood stuff, the same everything.
然后你和他们一起吃了几顿饭，深入了解之后，你会想：天哪，他们其实跟我差不多，他们也有同样沸腾的不安全感，同样的童年阴影，什么都一样。
And you just realize like we're successful in spite of a lot of our child, not, you know, like, everyone, everyone has this stuff, you know, my friend Max always says this thing that I love.
你就会明白，我们取得成功其实恰恰克服了许多童年带来的影响，不，你知道的，每个人、每个人都有这些问题，你知道，我的朋友马克斯总是说的一句话我很喜欢。
is actually told him that there's no such thing as a winner circle.
其实我告诉过他，根本没有什么赢家俱乐部。
You know, we think we're gonna get to a place where we're just gonna feel resolved and successful and I finally figured it out and cracked the champagne and it just never happens.
你知道的，我们以为自己会到达一个地方，在那里我们会感到一切都尘埃落定、获得成功，终于把人生琢磨透了，然后开香槟庆祝，但这从未发生过。
But it's the great fallacy.
但这却是一个巨大的谬论。
It's the great fallacy chasing that saying that does not exist.
追逐那个并不存在的说法，就是最大的谬论。
And I think that in some ways it's the overarching narrative of the show is the main character was obsessed with the finish line.
我认为在某些方面，这也是这部剧的整体叙事——主角痴迷于终点线。
He's obsessed with the goal post.
他痴迷于目标。
He even, even Marshall Lilly, the front porch, There's this idea that there's a moment when everyone's gonna exhale and just high five.
甚至，甚至是马歇尔和莉莉，还有那个前廊，大家总觉得会有那么一个时刻，所有人都会如释重负地松一口气，然后击掌庆贺。
But the truth of it was the thing that was the best was the, it was true, I mean it's the cliche of cliches, but it was the journey, it was the thing all along.
但事实是，最美好的东西其实是……没错，这是老生常谈的陈词滥调，但旅程本身、过程本身就是一切。
That's why you could have sold the story in 15 minutes is like, stop saying that, like no.
这就是为什么你本可以在15分钟内就把这个故事讲完，就像在说：别再唠叨了，根本不是这样的。
The whole thing is it had to be unspooled in this long ornate kind of narrative because that's where the gold is.
重点在于，它必须以这种漫长而华丽的叙事方式一点点展开，因为那才是真正的金矿所在。
Yeah, it's funny.
对，这挺有意思的。
Sometimes we get that comment from people on the internet, like, I love the show, but it could have all been told in 15 minutes.
有时我们在网上看到网友这样的评论：我喜欢这部剧，但其实15分钟就能讲完。
And I'm like, then there would have been no show for you to love.
而我想说的是，那这样的话，就不会有一部让你深爱的剧了。
So I guess it was okay to stretch it out.
所以我想，把它拉长也是可以的吧。
Well, all of those flaws and all of those emotional ups and downs are well-on exhibit.
嗯，所有这些缺点以及所有的情感起伏都展露无遗。
In today's episode, we're discussing, that was a transition.
在今天的节目中，我们要讨论的是……这真是一个神转折。
It was very good.
非常棒。
You guys feel that?
你们感觉到了吗？
That was professional podcasting right there.
这绝对是专业级别的播客。
Season two, man, for figuring it out.
第二季了嘛，总算摸清门道了。
Alec, tell us what episode we're talking about, when it aired and who wrote it, yeah?
亚历克，给我们讲讲我们今天要讨论的是哪一集，它是何时播出的，又是谁写的，好吗？
Absolutely.
当然。
This is the Scorpion and the Toad.
这一集是《蝎子与蟾蜍》（The Scorpion and the Toad）。
It originally aired on September 25th, 25, 2006, and it was written by Chris Harris.
它最初于2006年9月25日播出，由克里斯·哈里斯（Chris Harris）编剧。
Chris Harris.
克里斯·哈里斯。
Chris Harris, one of the all-timers.
克里斯·哈里斯，绝对是史上最强编剧之一。
If you're just tuning in for season two, we had Chris Harris' guest on the show, some going deep into season one, or maybe midway through it.
如果你是从第二季才开始收听的，我们在节目中曾邀请过克里斯·哈里斯作为嘉宾，深入探讨过第一季的内容，或者大概在第一季播到中段的时候。
Yeah, for the episode Game Night, if you haven't heard that, Well, go back and listen to Olive season one if you haven't heard it of this podcast, having made your mother a really, Chris was on and talked, we talked in depth about the episode, Game Nighting, but also just about, you know, I embarrassed Chris, Chris always turns red if you watch, if you can watch the YouTube clip, if he just turns red.
是的，对于“游戏之夜”那一集，如果你还没听过，去找来听听看，第一季的《老爸老妈浪漫史》如果你还没听过这个播客的话，克里斯曾上过节目，我们深入聊了“游戏之夜”那一集，还有，你知道的，我让克里斯很尴尬，如果你看YouTube片段的话，克里斯总是会脸红，他只要一上节目就会脸红。
He still has them when he turns red.
他脸红的时候依然很帅。
He's still very handsome, but he, yeah, well, he really is one of the all-time best premium writers and he, he just had this knack and you see it in this episode of just being very playful and clever and really as much as anyone on the staff, including Carter and myself, really using the narrator to shape jokes, really using the storytelling kind of superpowers the toolkit of how you can tell stories and how much mother Chris is really good at that.
他依然非常帅气，而且，是的，他真的是史上最顶级的优秀编剧之一，他有一种天赋，你在这集里也能看到，那就是非常调皮、聪明，而且和剧组里的任何人一样，包括卡特和我，真的会利用旁白来构思笑话，真的在运用讲故事的超能力，也就是如何讲故事的工具箱，克里斯在这方面真的很擅长。
One example in this episode, I really liked the cleverness of seeing the first version of Lilly's story of how great San Francisco was for her on the bus with all these wonderful characters.
这集里有一个例子，我真的很喜欢那种巧妙的设计，就是看到莉莉关于三藩市对她有多棒的第一个版本的故事，车上坐着各种各样美好的人物。
And then the reveal later that all the same dialogue just kind of out of one person's mouth, who is just a really weird kind of creepy dude that she was sitting next to on the bus.
然后后来揭晓，所有相同的对话其实都是从一个人嘴里说出来的，那个人只是她在车上旁边坐着的一个非常古怪、有点让人起鸡皮疙瘩的家伙。
That's, that's a, that feels like a very Chris Harris joke.
这，这感觉非常像是克里斯·哈里斯式的笑话。
Just the idea of like all of those words will perfectly mean something entirely different the second time.
就是那种所有这些词在第二次出现时会完全变成另一种意思的创意。
Well, also with the art teacher, that what he says, it's literally the same dialogue with.
还有美术老师那段，他说的话，字面上的台词完全是一样的。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, sorry, I mentioned that whole montage.
对，对，对，抱歉，我刚才说的是整个蒙太奇。
Yeah, it's literally, it's all the words are the same for all of those beats.
对， literalmente（字面意思），所有这些桥段里的词都是一样的。
Yeah, I love that.
是的，我太喜欢那个了。
It reminds me of, have you seen that thing online that's like, will you marry me as a marriage proposal?
这让我想起，你在网上见过那种梗吗，比如“will you marry me”（你愿意嫁给我吗）作为一个求婚？
And then it's, will you marry me is a proposal for a for some like will you marry and me.
然后它是，“will you marry me”（Will，你娶我吧）变成了对某个像will（威尔）和mary（玛丽）的人的提议。
Oh my God.
天哪。
That's a good one.
那个真不错。
And then it was like, will you marry me is like a caveman introduction or something like will you marry me?
然后还有，“will you marry me”就像是原始人的自我介绍什么的，比如“will, you marry me”（威尔，你嫁给我吧）。
Mary's introducing yourself to will.
玛丽在向威尔做自我介绍。
The caveman.
那个原始人。
Like will you marry me?
就像“will you marry me”？
Like basically I don't wear the stresses where the comma is where that but he does that.
基本上就是重音落在哪里，逗号在哪里，但他就是能做到这一点。
especially with the art teacher, I actually heard it, and I was like, it's so smart, the way the art teacher is flipped, you know?
尤其是美术老师那段，我当时听到的时候就想，美术老师那段的反转真的太聪明了，你知道吗？
Can I say that we got a comment from Jen J.
我能说我们收到了一条来自珍·J·坦（Jen J. Tan）的评论吗？
Tan who said, I'm an English teacher and have used the two contrasting clips of Lillian San Francisco to help my students practice pronunciation.
她说：“我是一名英语老师，我用莉莉在三藩市那两个对比鲜明的片段来帮助我的学生练习发音。”
It's a great example of how changing word stress and emphasis can really affect the meaning of what you say, even when the words may be exactly the same.
这是一个很好的例子，说明改变单词的重音和语调如何真正影响你所说的话的含义，即使这些词可能完全一样。
Yeah, Chris is really good at that stuff.
是的，克里斯在处理这些事情上真的很有一套。
He's written some really brilliant children's books, but they're like Shel Silverstein, Oscar for Adults 2, and he's just very playful with words.
他写过一些非常棒的儿童读物，有点像谢尔·西尔弗斯坦（Shel Silverstein）或成人版的奥斯卡2，而且他对文字的玩味非常浓厚。
And I think he really, you really see that in this episode.
我觉得在这一集中，你真的能深深地感受到这一点。
I mean, I'm also delighted that how I met your mother is being used to educate the youth of America.
我的意思是，我也很高兴看到《老爸老妈浪漫史》被用来教育美国的青少年。
That's amazing, I know, I skipped right over that.
太惊人了，我知道，我刚才直接忽略了这一点。
We hear it all the time that people learn English from the show, people study it in classes and college and stuff, it's very cool for our little CBS sitcom from 2005.
我们经常听到有人通过这部剧学习英语，有人在课程和大学里研究它，对我们这个2005年出品的小小CBS情景喜剧来说，这真的很酷。
This is jumping a little bit ahead, but I wonder what a non-native English speaker would say.
这稍微有点提前，但我很好奇非母语英语学习者会怎么说。
What is redonk?
什么是redonk？
And I wrote you this little day to send you in New York City.
我给你写了这段小日程，让你在纽约市发送。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
And now, back to the show.
现在，言归正传。
Craig, just give us a little armchair summary of what this episode's about, where we left our heroes and where we are today.
克雷格，请给我们大致总结一下这一集的内容，以及我们的主角们之前在什么地方，今天又处于什么状态。
Yeah, so we, episode one of season two ends with this reveal that Lily is back from San Francisco, but nobody knows yet.
好的，第二季第一集以莉莉从旧金山回来但还没人知道的悬念结束。
Marshall has been a terrible mess all summer.
整个夏天马修都一团糟。
He's finally starting to show some signs of life.
他终于开始显露出一些生机了。
And so we meet him in this episode where he says, I got to get back out there somehow.
所以在这一集里我们看到他说：‘我无论如何得重新振作起来。’
Barney is very excited to be the wingman to Marshall now that Ted's dead to him because Ted's in relationship with Robin.
因为泰德跟罗宾在一起了，在巴尼眼里泰德已经‘死’了，所以巴尼非常兴奋能成为马修的僚机。
So Barney's like, it's you now, Marshall.
因此巴尼觉得：‘现在是你了，马修。’
It's all been leading here.
一切都是为了这一刻。
you're my guy.
‘你就是我的搭档。’
So Barney takes Marshall under his wing to get out there and meet a lady.
于是巴尼把马修纳入羽翼之下，带他出去结识女士。
It's based.
这就对了。
The reason it's called the scorpion on the toad is there's a parable of the scorpion on the toad.
这一集之所以叫《蝎子与蟾蜍》，是因为有一个关于蝎子和蟾蜍的寓言。
That is, I guess I'll just say it because we never explained it in the episode.
我想我就直说了吧，因为我们在剧里从来没解释过。
It is there's a scorpion and there's a toad and there's a stream.
大意就是有一只蝎子、一只蟾蜍和一条小溪。
There's a river or something.
一条河什么的。
And the scorpion says, I got to get to the other side.
蝎子说，我得去河对岸。
Can I ride on you, Mr. Toad?
我能搭你的背吗，蟾蜍先生？
And Mr. Toad says, Yes, but if you were to sting me, we will both die.
蟾蜍先生说，可以，但如果你蜇我，我们都会死。
And the scorpion says, I'm not gonna sting you.
蝎子说，我不会蜇你的。
Come on, we'll just be a team.
来吧，我们组个团队。
We'll just get across the stream together.
我们一起过河就行了。
And the toad, the sweet, sweet portote goes, okay.
然后那只蟾蜍，那只心地善良的好蟾蜍说，好吧。
And he puts the scorpion in his back and starts swimming across and halfway across the river.
它把蝎子背在背上开始游过去，游到河中央时。
The scorpion stings him.
蝎子蜇了它。
And as they both start to drown, the toad says, why did you do that?
当两人开始下沉时，蟾蜍问，你为什么要这么做？
And the scorpion goes, because it's my nature.
蝎子说，因为这就是我的天性。
and they both die.
然后两人都死了。
Look, and Barney is the scorpion in the sense.
你看，从某种意义上说，巴尼就是那只蝎子。
Yeah, you know, it's, it just, it continues to delight me that you can just watch how I met your mother as a show about a bunch of people in New York City at a certain time looking for love and you know, growing up.
是的，你知道，我仍然感到非常高兴的是，你可以把《老爸老妈浪漫史》当成一部讲述纽约市一群人在特定时期寻找爱情和成长的剧集来看。
And you can also say, hey, that's John Steinbeck reference.
你也可以说，嘿，那是约翰·斯坦贝克的梗。
That's F Scott's Fitzgerald.
那是F·斯科特·菲茨杰拉德。
That's an ASAP fable.
那是伊索寓言。
Like, there's, you give people multiple layers through which to experience and enjoy this thing.
就像，你给人们提供了多层体验和享受这部剧的方式。
And for people who are alert to those Easter eggs, you know, there's the, I know what, I think it's the episode of Marshall, and I won't spoil anything, but there's an episode where it's just a countdown, like visual countdown.
对于那些留意这些彩蛋的人来说，你知道，有一个，我记得是马歇尔的那集，我不会剧透任何内容，但有一集里面有一个倒计时，类似于视觉上的倒计时。
You see all these numbers ticking, ticking, ticking down.
你能看到所有这些数字在滴答滴答地倒数。
And a lot of people didn't notice that on the first watch.
很多人在第一次看的时候都没有注意到这一点。
That's something that you can get alert to, because it's not overly, you know, you don't hit him over the head.
这是你可以去留心发现的东西，因为它不是很过分，你知道，它不会直接拍到你脸上去。
And I think that respecting the intelligence of the viewer and not leading them in a way that was insulting, but you know, like Billy Wilder said, like letting them put two and two together, I think that's part of the pleasure of the show, especially for repeat viewings.
而且我认为尊重观众的智力，不以一种侮辱性的方式引导他们，而是像比利·怀尔德说的那样，让他们自己把线索拼凑起来，我认为这正是这部剧的乐趣所在，尤其是对于重复观看的人来说。
Yeah, yeah, I hope so.
对，对，我希望如此。
That was definitely the goal.
这绝对是我们的目标。
It's nice to hear you say that.
很高兴听到你这么说。
I think we did all make that show.
我觉得我们确实都参与制作了那样一部剧。
And yeah, I was impressed, and other than instruct me about that parable and how that episode kind of plays with that parable, is it's funny, it's season two, we're trying to still build an audience, we're still getting a lot of notes, like make sure everyone's likable, make sure, make sure the show fits right in there with King of Queens and two and a half men, and it's just like, ah, it's just a fun show.
是的，我印象深刻，除了告诉我那个寓言以及那一集是如何运用那个寓言的之外，很有趣的是，那是第二季，我们还在努力建立观众群，我们仍然收到很多意见，比如确保每个人都讨人喜欢，确保这部剧能完美融入《后中之王》和《好汉两个半》这样的风格中，感觉就像，啊，这只是一部有趣的剧。
But essentially this episode, and this is the daring of this episode, and it really struck me, essentially this episode's question is like, is Barney a sociopath?
但本质上这一集，这也是这一集的冒险之处，它真的打动了我，本质上这一集的问题就像是，巴尼是个反社会者吗？
Like this episode is essentially like American psycho, you know, I mean, like Barney cannot stop himself from continually stealing these women that he knows Marshall's a mess.
就像这一集本质上就像《美国精神病人》，你知道的，我是说，巴尼无法克制自己，不断地去抢这些女人，他明明知道马歇尔现在一团糟。
He knows Marshall needs a woman.
他知道马歇尔需要一个女人。
He knows he wants that for Marshall.
他知道他希望马歇尔得到幸福。
He loves Marshall, but there's something in his nature that he just cannot resist the chance to have a conquest of his own.
他爱马歇尔，但他的天性中有些东西让他无法抗拒去征服的诱惑。
And of course at the end, there's that kind of like moral debate, philosophical debate, which is probably bullshit, but Barney kind of implies, but maybe it's not entirely bullshit.
当然在最后，有一种类似道德辩论、哲学辩论的东西，这可能都是废话，但巴尼暗示过，不过也许这并非完全是废话。
Kind of implies, I'm doing this for your own good.
有点暗示说，我这么做是为了你好。
I told you being single was so funny, it's like being at a candy store, it's not, it's a post-apocalyptic wasteland, it's every man for himself, and that's the best lesson you.
我告诉过你单身有多有趣，就像在糖果店一样，其实不然，这是个末日后的废土，每个人都在为自己而战，这是给你最好的教训。
That's what you need to learn, having lived in a captivity of couplehood for so long.
这就是你需要学到的，在长期处于恋爱关系的囚禁中生活之后。
And I think Barney on some level does think he's offering up that lesson, but also he just wants to steal these women.
我认为巴尼在某种程度上确实认为他是在提供这一课，但同时他只是想抢走这些女人。
And it's just so compulsive and like really crazy of him.
这太强迫性了，而且他真的很疯狂。
But it's just so funny.
但这也太搞笑了。
It's kind of a dark, it's a dark storyline.
这有点黑暗，这是一个黑暗的故事线。
It's really weird the storyline.
这条故事线真的很奇怪。
On this topic, our friend Swarly memes says, without giving away Barney's real motive later this season, I wanted to ask about the psychology in this episode.
关于这个话题，我们的朋友斯瓦利迷（Swarly memes）说，在不透露本季后面巴尼的真实动机的情况下，我想问一下这一集里的心理学。
Barney keeps blocking Marshall even though it hurts their friendship.
巴尼不断阻挠马歇尔，尽管这伤害了他们的友谊。
The fable says the scorpion stings because it's in his nature.
寓言里说蝎子蜇人是因为这是它的天性。
Did you write Barney that way as someone who can't escape his nature or someone making a choice to hurt Marshall anyway, or neither him spoilers, and weren't you a bit scared to make Barney come across almost like a psychopath by making him the scorpion?
你把巴尼写成这样一个无法摆脱天性的人，还是一个无论如何都要选择伤害马歇尔的人，或者都不是？还有剧透一下，把巴尼写得像个蝎子，让他看起来几乎像个精神病患者，你当时难道不有点害怕吗？
Please talk about this.
请谈谈这个。
I'm surprised that we did it this early in season two because we probably, I bet the network would have preferred we did an episode where Barney was less evil than this episode, David, just to be like, let's get more people in and liking everybody.
我很惊讶我们在第二季这么早就做了这一集，因为我敢说，电视网可能更希望我们拍一集巴尼不那么邪恶的剧集，大卫，只是为了吸引更多人来看并且喜欢每一个人。
But I think the episode, it has this kind of tension and it's funny because we went to start with Barney.
但我认为这一集，它有这种张力，而且很有趣，因为我们是从巴尼开始的。
And I think he can't stop himself at this moment.
我觉得此刻他无法控制自己。
Through the long arc of the entire series, you see Barney try to be better than this at other times.
贯穿整部剧集的漫长发展，你会看到巴尼在其他时候试图表现得更好。
But right here, he's just not.
但就在此时此刻，他并没有这样做。
In some ways, it is a kinder narrative to speak of it in terms of compulsion or addiction.
从某种程度上讲，如果从强迫症或上瘾的角度来谈论它，这是一种更温和的叙事方式。
And because if he was actually making a choice, it's almost worse.
因为如果他是真的在做选择，那几乎就更糟了。
It's like you're aware of what you're doing and you're hurt.
就像你知道自己在做什么，而且你受到了伤害。
But there's something about the compulsivity of it.
但这种强迫行为本身有些特别之处。
It's like, to put it in like addiction terms, he's powerless.
这就好比，用成瘾的话来说，他是无能为力的。
He's powerless, you know, and- And the scorpion dies.
他无能为力，你知道，而且——蝎子死了。
The scorpion is powerless to stop himself and dies because he can't stop himself.
蝎子无法阻止自己，最终死去，因为他控制不住自己。
So it is that part of it too.
所以这其中也有这部分原因。
And Barney at the end, you know, crashes and burns gets his comeuppance and has spent, you know, there's, we don't see him do this exact thing in Marshall.
而且巴尼在最后，你知道的，自食恶果、遭到报应，并且花时间——你知道的，我们没看到他在马歇尔身上做过这种具体的事。
This is the one episode where he's like this.
这是他表现成这样的唯一一集。
But yeah, I would say that that's a good question because I think we were a little nervous doing this, but we were enamored of this idea of playing out this parable.
但话又说回来，我觉得这是一个好问题，因为我觉得我们在拍这段时其实有点紧张，但我们非常喜欢演绎这个寓言的想法。
And the idea of like Marshall in the end, I really liked when Marshall leaves dejected.
还有最后马歇尔的那个桥段，当马歇尔沮丧地离开时，我真的很喜欢。
And he's been absolutely eviscerated by Barney instead of lifted up by him.
他被巴尼彻底击溃了，而不是被他振奋起来。
And that's when he runs into Lily.
也就是在这个时候，他遇到了莉莉。
And Lily says, can we get back together?
莉莉说，我们能复合吗？
And now Marshall has this incredible boost of power and kind of status in that scene.
此时马歇尔在这场戏中获得了难以置信的力量感和某种地位的提升。
All of a sudden Marshall has walked out from getting the shit kicked out of him to like having his dream come true of she's coming back to him, a bit chastened.
马歇尔突然之间从被痛殴得落花流水，变成了梦想成真——她要回到他身边了，而且多少带着点羞愧。
She admits right off the bat that she did not like being away from him and apart from him.
她开门见山地承认自己不喜欢离开他和远离他的生活。
She says we get back together with me and Marshall actually is a little bit hard-hearted in that moment, not cold-hearted, hard-hearted.
她说我们复合吧，跟我在一起吧，而马歇尔在那一刻其实有点硬心肠，不是冷酷，是心肠变硬了。
He's a little bit firm like, no, I'm not ready.
他态度有点强硬地说，不，我还没准备好。
I'm not ready to just say yes.
我还没准备好就这么答应。
You were the one that this was your idea.
当初这是你的主意，你才是那个提出的人。
I'm not there yet.
我还没到那一步。
And did he get some of that strength from going through that with Barney?
难道他从与巴尼的这段经历中获得了一些力量吗？
Did he get a little bit like a little bit, I don't know, like a little bit firmer about things because he's just saw the reality of what it's like.
他是不是变得稍微、我不知道，对事情的态度稍微强硬了一点，因为他刚刚看到了现实究竟是什么样子的。
I don't know.
我不知道。
There's something about where he is emotionally when he walks out that bar when he runs into Lily that I think tracks.
他走出那家酒吧、遇到莉莉时他的那种情感状态，我觉得非常符合逻辑。
And yeah, I don't know.
而且，我不知道。
I feel like I love the way that episode ends.
我觉得我好喜欢这一集的结尾方式。
Well, it also, I feel like there's a decision made maybe in season two, where Barney isn't actually as hapless as he is with women in the first, you know, the question in the first season we were talking early is like, is he, does he pull all these women, or does he just- He strikes out a lot.
嗯，而且我觉得，第二季可能做出过这样一个决定：巴尼其实并不像他在第一季里对待女性时那么无能——你知道的，我们在早期讨论第一季时的问题是，他是真的能泡到所有这些女人，还是他只是——他经常碰壁。
He strikes out a lot.
他经常碰壁。
And season one.
而在第一季里。
It's a, you know, he's essentially a pickup artist, right?
他基本上是个搭讪艺术家，对吧？
So those guys, my friend was one of those.
所以那些家伙，我的朋友就曾是其中之一。
I don't know anything about the specifics.
我对具体细节一无所知。
What was that friends name?
那个朋友叫什么名字？
His name was Hosh Padner.
他叫霍什·帕德纳。
No, no, I just want to be clear.
不，不，我只是想澄清一下。
I'm not, I was never a part of pickup culture, but I do know that part of it is becoming immune to rejection.
我没有——我从来不是搭讪文化的一部分，但我确实知道其中的一部分是变得对拒绝免疫。
Like it's a numbers game, right?
就像这是一个概率游戏，对吧？
Like you just cycle through and you train yourself to not have your ego shattered by a rejection because you just keep going.
就像你不断循环，训练自己不要因为被拒绝而让自我意识崩溃，因为你只要一直坚持下去就行。
And he does seem to be on that, but there is something in this episode that he, and in later episodes, especially this season where he is, he does get the women, you know, even his whole apartment being structured around getting women out, you know, after the one night stand.
他似乎确实处于这种状态，但这一集里有些东西——还有后面的剧集，特别是这一季，他确实能泡到女人，你知道的，甚至他整个公寓的布局都是为了在发生一夜情后把女人送走。
So, you know, there was a choice that you guys made, and I don't know where and how that choice was made, but it started to be like, he wasn't just all talk.
所以，你知道的，这是你们做出的一个选择，我不知道这个选择是在哪里以及如何做出的，但它开始表现为：他不仅仅是嘴上说说。
Yeah, he started, like, in this episode, he successfully, if we really take him at his word, He successfully hooks up with all of these women, stealing them from Marshall.
对，他开始——就像在这集里，如果我们真的相信他的话，他成功地跟所有这些女性发生了关系，把她们从马歇尔身边抢走了。
And it probably is the episode in which he's most successful and to date in series by having done that.
这很可能是迄今为止他在整部剧中通过这样做而取得最大成功的一集。
And it was just a plot mechanism to play out the scorpion and the toe of it all.
这只是一种剧情机制，用来演绎“蝎子与青蛙”的寓言。
Marshall just keeps being that toe and keeps thinking, he's gonna do the right thing.
马歇尔一直在扮演那只青蛙，并且一直以为巴尼会做正确的事。
But it did make him more successful than I sometimes like him to be.
但这确实让他比我有时希望的那样更成功了。
I actually like him when he fails better.
其实我更喜欢他失败时的样子。
Well, he's more sympathetic.
嗯，他那样更讨人喜欢。
He stays in the kind of heart of the audience a little bit more than when he.
比起他成功的时候，他更能留在观众的心里。
But I will say, I think you guys did something very smart at the end, which is you had to give him a come up and you had to, you had to give him a humiliation at the end.
不过我要说的是，我觉得你们在最后做了一件非常聪明的事，那就是你们必须给他一个报应，必须在最后给他一个羞辱。
So it would be like, you know, and also the one too, like using Lily, like it's, it's very smart.
所以这就好像是，你知道的，还有利用莉莉这一招，这——非常聪明。
I really loved, I'd forgotten that, I forgot what we did kind of at the end.
我真的很喜欢，我都快忘了这出了，我忘了我们在结尾时是怎么处理的。
And I was like, oh, that's clever.
然后我就想，哦，这太巧妙了。
Maybe, maybe it hit me more than it did when we did it, which is just, it was actually very important.
也许它给我的触动比我们创作它的时候还要深，实际上这非常重要。
We wanted this episode to end with Marshall Lilly not getting back together.
我们希望这一集的结尾是马歇尔和莉莉并没有复合。
We just wanted that condition to last longer because it was a good story motor to show these two characters apart for a while.
我们只是想让这种状态持续更长时间，因为让这两个角色分开一段时间是一个很好的剧情推动力。
And it also just fell honest.
而且这也让人觉得很真实。
It wasn't like, I know she's back and now the summer's over so now she's back and it was that easy.
感觉不是那种，我知道她回来了，现在夏天结束了所以她回来了，一切就这么简单。
We wanted it to maybe seem like it was going that way and then not to not go that way.
我们希望它看起来好像要往那个方向发展，但最终却没有那样发展。
And I really liked that she, they didn't get back together, but there was a sweetness and there was a missing each other in their little conversation.
我真的很喜欢他们虽然没有复合，但他们的简短对话中透着一种甜蜜和对彼此的思念。
And that when Marshall said, can you help me in this way?
当马歇尔说，你能帮我这个忙吗？
She does it.
她照做了。
She yes and is him in that improv game because she loves him.
在这场即兴表演中，她顺着马歇尔的话演了下去，因为她爱他。
And she's like, I don't even know why I'm doing this necessarily if she thinks about it too hard.
她心里想，如果仔细想想，我甚至不知道自己为什么要这么做。
Like maybe that would be disturbing if Marshall is, you know, interested in one of these women.
比如，如果马歇尔对其中某个女人感兴趣，那可能会让人觉得不安吧。
But she just fucking does it and goes in there and it's so funny and so deeply stupid how she comes in, goes out and comes back in with a beret, and now she's the other sister.
但她他妈的还是去做了，走进去，太搞笑了，而且她戴着贝雷帽走进来、走出去又走回来，现在她成了另一个姐妹，这简直蠢透了。
It was so, really my wife and I are watching a week.
真的，我和我妻子当时一周看一集。
That's the hardest we laughed in the whole episode because it's so stupid.
那是整集里我们笑得最厉害的一次，因为太蠢了。
But I realize it was actually an important step in what happens a few episodes later, which is Marshall and Lily getting back together and showing just, there is that connection.
但我意识到，这实际上是几集之后发生的事情的重要一步，也就是马歇尔和莉莉复合，并且正好展示了：他们之间确实存在那种联系。
She will still do that for him, even though it's as stupid as saying in the world.
她仍然会为他做那种事，尽管那是世界上最蠢的话。
You know, just comedically like, like her is saying, you know, you gave me chlamydia and throwing the drink in the face.
你知道的，纯粹从喜剧效果来说，就像她说“你让我得了衣原体”然后把酒泼在脸上。
That's funny enough.
这就已经够好笑了。
That could've been it.
本来可以就此结束的。
But the topping it with like the identical twin is so, it's just like it's squeezing it just a little more drop out of it that is so satisfying.
但加上“同卵双胞胎”这个设定，就好像从里面硬是又挤出了一滴油水，让人感到无比满足。
And that's why there are twins.
这就是为什么要有双胞胎。
It wasn't like, it'd be funny if Barney's going after two cute blonde twins because that's what Barney would do.
并不是说，“如果巴尼去追求两个可爱的金发双胞胎会很有趣，因为巴尼就会这么干”。
No, we came up with that idea specifically because we came up with the way Lily.
不，我们之所以想出这个主意，完全是因为我们想到了莉莉会怎么做。
The way Lily would do that.
我们是通过反向推导才找到了这个结果。
And we sort of reverse engineered it to get there.
这就是为什么会有双胞胎。
And that's why they're twins.
You know, it's funny.
你知道这很有趣。
We always talk about what a great actress, Alison Hannigan is, but it's funny that Lily herself is like a pretty game actor in certain plots and schemes.
我们总是讨论阿莉森·汉妮根是个多伟大的演员，但有趣的是，莉莉本人在某些剧情和计划中也是一个非常配合的演员。
Like, you know, a couple episodes later, Barney and lists her in a plot that scheme that she plays really willingly and kind of delightfully.
比如，你知道的，几集之后，巴尼把她拉进了一个她非常乐意且带点愉快地去演的阴谋诡计中。
That's a good point.
这是一个很好的观点。
In world's greatest couple, she does another ruse and really commits.
在《世界上最棒的情侣》中，她又搞了一场骗局，而且真的全身心投入。
And like really, yeah, that's funny.
就像真的，对，这太搞笑了。
Lily can yes end.
莉莉很懂得顺着别人的话演下去。
And that scene between her and Marshall that leads up to that is so sweet and her eyes are too tearing up and she wants him back so badly.
她和马歇尔在那之前的那场戏是那么甜蜜，她的眼眶也湿润了，她是那么渴望他回到她身边。
She, that's another amazing Allison Haddigan moment is the only other point of time.
她——那是另一个惊艳的阿莉森·汉妮根的高光时刻，也是仅有的另一个时间节点。
On the street with.
在大街上。
On the street when I have the little conversation and Marshall says, no, I'm not, no.
在大街上，当我们进行那个简短的对话，马歇尔说，不，我不是，不。
We're not gonna get back together yet.
我们还没准备好复合。
We're still on this journey and I don't know what's gonna happen and she the way her eyes well up with tears.
我们还在经历这个过程，我不知道会发生什么，然后她眼中泛起泪光的那个样子。
Oh my God, yeah.
哦天哪，是的。
Heartbreaking and you want them to be together but you respect Marshall because she's the one who sort of ended it and said, we need this and he's finally gotten to the place where he can agree on some level.
太心碎了，你希望他们能在一起，但你又很尊敬马歇尔，因为当初是她提出了分手并说“我们需要这样”，而他终于达到了某种程度上能够表示赞同的境界。
Like maybe we do need time apart to figure ourselves out and he was great being strong and that's- She kind of is like, she's devastated, but she kind of like, there's something about her accepting her fate and accepting the kind of karma of like, I have to live through the discomfort of this.
就像也许我们确实需要时间分开来认识自己，而他表现得很坚强，那就是——她有点像是，她虽然心碎了，但她有点像，某种程度上她接受了自己的命运，接受了那种因果报应，就好像，我必须经历这种不适感。
Yes, yes, that's what you see in her eyes.
对，对，你在她眼中看到的就是这个。
She's crying when she's accepting it.
她在接受的时候哭了。
It's really good acting.
这演技真的很好。
Yeah.
对。
Shout out to Ali.
向Ali致敬。
Um, so, uh, just going back to, uh, some specifics from the episode, the first thing I wrote down was the candy flash forward, you know, of like, trying to come up with the perfect candy name for breasts.
嗯，那么，呃，回到，呃，这集的一些细节上来，我写下的第一件事就是糖果闪回，你知道的，就是试着给胸部起一个完美的糖果名字。
That's another very Chris Harris, like fast forward, use the narrative, but yeah, that I love that.
那是另一个非常克里斯·哈里斯式的风格，比如快进，利用叙事，但是，是的，我太喜欢那个了。
But you know what I thought, and this, tell me if this is wrong, that in the writer's room, you guys get this idea, like candies, breasts, and everyone starts pitching ideas, right?
但你知道我在想什么吗，而且这个，告诉我这错没错，就是在编剧室里，你们得到了这个想法，就像糖果、胸部，然后每个人都开始抛出点子，对吧？
Now, you couldn't list all the ideas, but you do have this clever thing.
现在，你不可能列出所有的点子，但你们确实有这样一个巧妙的安排。
Like, to me, it was a bit that looked like, oh, this is just the writer's room burning through their own ideas and Marshall and Ted, and it's the three of them, right?
就像，对我来说，这听起来像是一个包袱，哦，这只是编剧室在把他们自己的点子榨干，马歇尔和泰德，是他们三个，对吧？
It's the three guys.
是他们三个人。
It's the three guys, right?
是他们三个人，对吧？
And I spent an hour on this.
我在这上面花了一个小时。
There's been an hour on this.
在这上面花了一个小时。
It's just also what we did in the writer's show.
这也是我们在编剧室里做的事。
And, you know, this is so, this is, Jason had a song first season that he started singing.
而且，你知道，这就是，杰森在第一季时有一首歌，他开始唱起来。
And it was, I'll just say it was about buttholes, that's all I'm going to say, okay?
那是，我只能说那是关于屁眼的，我只能说这么多了，好吗？
I started adding verses to this.
我开始给这首歌加歌词。
And we spent days, like we spent days adding verses and trying to make each other laugh.
我们花了几天时间，比如我们花了几天时间加歌词，试图逗笑彼此。
I don't know this.
我不知道这个。
This is the first time I hear you about this.
这是我第一次听你提起这事。
We then went to, what was that restaurant?
我们后来去了，那是哪家餐厅？
It's on Beverly, Dominix.
在贝弗利大街上，Dominix。
Yeah, yeah, Dominix.
对，对，Dominix。
The original Dominix.
最初的Dominix。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
We went there, we sat outside in silence with cocktails, just writing more verses and trying to make each other laugh.
我们去了那里，拿着鸡尾酒在外面静静地坐着，只是写更多的歌词，试图逗笑彼此。
Like that was our like post-work thing.
就像那是我们的下班后消遣一样。
And it's the same thing.
这也是一样的。
It's just like you get an idea that feels like comedically fertile.
就像你得到了一个感觉在喜剧上很有潜力的点子。
And you just ride it, you ride it into this hand.
然后你就一直顺着它往下搞，你把它一路搞到底。
like, you're gonna take it as long as you can.
就像，你要尽可能长时间地把它玩下去。
Yeah.
对。
Well, that's a writer's room.
好吧，这就是编剧室。
And that's what you guys were doing.
这就是你们当时在做的事。
And I think that we've done that.
我想我们以前也做过。
We did that forum other times, the fast forward through and jump out to hear one thing and then fast forward through.
我们在其他时候也为论坛做过这个，快进然后跳出来听一句话，然后再快进。
That became kind of a low key runner in the series.
这在剧集里变成了一种低调的惯例。
We did that a bunch of times.
我们做过好多次。
This was the first time I think.
我想这是第一次。
There might have been one in season one, actually.
第一季里可能也有过一个，其实。
I can't remember, but it makes the joke so much funnier in that forum.
我记不清了，但在那个形式下，这个笑话变得好笑得多。
because if you sat there and just heard a whole bunch of them for a whole minute, it would get old, but just like popping through and imagining the ones you're not hearing, that's why it works.
因为如果你坐在那里，连续听整整一分钟的各种名字，就会听腻了，但像这样弹出来，去想象那些你没听到的名字，这就是它管用的原因。
What the implication is when you start thinking about it is like, oh, actually all candy sounds like breasts.
当你开始思考时，其暗示的意思是，哦，实际上所有的糖果听起来都像胸部。
Like if you're just going with the film, they all work, you know?
就像如果你顺着这个梗往下想，它们全都能行，你知道吗？
Yeah.
对。
And I love them being idiots together, the three of them.
我喜欢他们三个在一起犯傻的样子。
It's a good like bro moment, three dudes can sit at a bar and do that for one hour, that can actually happen.
这真是一个很好的哥们儿时刻，三个大老爷们可以坐在酒吧里那样搞上一个小时，这确实会发生。
And it shows like if you drop Robin into that booth or Lily into that booth, the conversation's different.
这也说明，如果你把罗宾扔进那个卡座，或者把莉莉扔进那个卡座，对话就会不一样。
Yeah, so like Barney can be like gross with Ted and Marshall in a way that Lily or Robin would be like, would needle him for or Ted might even be a little more performatively outraged at Barney's grossness when Robin or Lily are in the booth.
对，所以巴尼可以和泰德、马歇尔表现得很恶心，而莉莉或罗宾会拿这个开涮，或者当罗宾或莉莉也在卡座里时，泰德甚至可能会对巴尼的恶心表现出更多表演性质的愤怒。
That's right.
没错。
Then he would be if it was just the three of them.
比只有他们三个人的时候要多。
Yeah, and I like that subtle, like the subtle difference of their energy is three dudes hanging out.
对，我喜欢那种微妙之处，他们精力的微妙不同之处在于那是三个好基友在闲逛。
And I really liked that moment.
我真的很喜欢那个时刻。
I loved the Lily reveal.
我超爱莉莉登场的那个镜头。
I just thought it was good, like Pam Fryman filmmaking.
我只是觉得那拍得很好，就像帕姆·弗莱曼式的电影语言。
And I thought, you know, the thing about like so many questions, like what was I going to say?
而且我觉得，你知道，关于那么多问题的那些事，比如我刚才要说什么来着？
And just your hair is adorable.
还有你的发型真可爱。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, that was great.
对，对，对，对，对，那太棒了。
And then that was them like the two of them having a lady bond energy.
然后那是他们两个闺蜜情深的感觉。
That's them without the guys.
那是没有男人们在场时的她们。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
It was funny.
这挺搞笑的。
together, they talk about boobs and when women are together, they talk about hair.
男人们聚在一起时，他们谈论胸部；而女人们聚在一起时，她们谈论发型。
Let's be very gender normative.
咱们就搞得很符合性别规范吧。
It's not the most original, but it works a matter.
这虽然不是最有创意的，但确实管用。
Yeah.
对。
When when Marshall's trying to, to talk to the woman, he says, sweat, like this smelly water coming out of your skin.
当马歇尔试图跟那个女人搭讪时，他说，汗，就像从你皮肤里流出来的臭水。
He plays that so great the way he just, he does not know how to talk to a woman who's not really, he just does.
他演得太棒了，他就是不知道该怎么和一个并不是真心想聊的女人说话，他就是不会。
Yeah.
对。
That must have been like a fun writer's room tea, like you tee that up like expressing interest in a woman for the first time in a decade and he has no idea how to do it go.
那一定是个很好玩的编剧室点子，就像你抛出这样一个设定：十年里第一次对一个女人表达兴趣，而他完全不知道该怎么做，开始吧。
Yeah.
对。
Like, like, such a fun prompt for for good comedy writers.
就像，对优秀的喜剧编剧来说，这是一个多有趣的提示。
Yeah, yeah, it's a good bit and but but but it like the weirdness of sweat being smelly water was a was a delightful.
对，对，这是一个很好的包袱，但是，但是，但是那种把汗水形容成臭水的诡异感，真是一个绝妙的。
I don't remember it was Chris and the writers doing it.
我不记得是克里斯还是编剧们想出来的。
But I rewatching it.
但我在重看的时候，我就想：这是一个非常真实且诡异的细节。
I was like, That's a really good visceral weird detail.
从你皮肤里流出来的臭水。
Smelly water that comes out of your skin.
好吧，再见。
All right, bye.
And it's also like, it's both like, it would make you go, I need to get away from this person.
而且这也是，它既会让人觉得，我得离这个人远点。
And also, when you think about it, it's like, I know what he's saying.
同时，当你仔细想想，又会觉得，我懂他在说什么。
It is smelly water that comes out.
那确实是从皮肤里流出来的臭水。
It is weird.
这挺诡异的。
It's real.
这是真的。
It's like, he's got a point.
就像，他说得有道理。
He's got a point.
他说得有道理。
And it's not a terrible way to describe it.
而且这也不算是一种太糟糕的描述。
It's just not a sexy way to talk.
它只是不是一种性感的说话方式。
It's not an opener.
这不是个搭讪开场白。
It's not what you would to lead with?
这不是你该用来开头的话。
Yeah, that's a three drinks in, you can say.
对，那是喝了三杯酒之后你才能说出口的话。
Smelly water.
臭水。
And this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you, knew who you were sitting.
这个老头，他……爱上了你，知道你坐在哪。
And now, commercials.
现在，进入广告。
Hey, I'm Carl Radke.
嘿，我是卡尔·拉德克。
You might know me from Bravo's Summer House, but on my podcast More Life, I get your favorite reality stars off the clock and into the conversations you don't usually get to hear.
你可能通过美国精彩电视台的《夏日山庄》认识我，但在我的播客《更多生活》中，我将带你走进你最喜欢的真人秀明星们的下班时间，听听那些你平时听不到的对话。
The deep stuff, the vulnerable stuff, the uncomfortable stuff.
那些深沉的、脆弱的、不安的内容。
I've sat down with C.R.
我和 C.R.
Miller, Derinda Medley, Tom Schwartz, Lindsey Hubbard, and a whole lot more.
米勒、德琳达·梅德利、汤姆·施瓦茨、林赛·哈伯德以及许多其他人进行了深度交谈。
We get into relationships growing up, the messy stuff, and everything that happens when the cameras aren't rolling.
我们探讨了成长过程中的恋爱关系、那些剪不断理还乱的麻烦事，以及摄像机关机后发生的一切。
New episodes of More Life every week, listen wherever you get your podcasts or watch on YouTube.
每周都有《More Life》的新期节目，请在各大播客平台收听或在 YouTube 上观看。
End of commercials, back to show.
广告结束，回到节目。
You guys really lean into Barney the Magician in this episode.
在这集里，你们真的很深入地探讨了“魔术师巴尼”这个梗。
Oh my God.
噢，天哪。
Yeah.
是的。
And this was really the beginning of, I think we teased it a little in season one, but this was like, he uses this.
这其实是一个开端，我觉得我们在第一季里稍微铺垫了一下，但这次就像是，他用上了这一招。
This is in his arsenal of tactics to get women.
这是他用来泡妞的战术库中的一部分。
Yeah, it's so funny.
对，太搞笑了。
And it's really Neil.
而且这确实是尼尔本人。
Neil really loves and does, and like Neil's member of the Magic Castle.
尼尔真的很喜欢也经常这么做，而且尼尔还是魔术城堡的会员。
Like he, whenever we did these things, he would bring in the stuff.
每当我们要拍这些内容时，他就会把道具带过来。
Like he, I think that was just his, he just had that stuff.
就像他，我觉得这就是他的风格，他身上就自带这些东西。
Or he would bring in like his magic consultant friend.
或者他会把他的魔术顾问朋友带过来。
People always think like, what part was improvised?
人们总是在想，哪一部分是即兴发挥的？
We should just say every magic trick was just Neil doing it in the moment.
我们直说吧，每一个魔术其实都是尼尔当时即兴表演的。
We didn't know it.
我们之前都不知道。
That's not true.
其实也不是这样。
Kneel would live for the moments, he got to sort of bring in stuff like that, it was very cool.
尼尔非常享受那种能把这类东西带入进来的时刻，非常酷。
It was really a part of his personality.
这确实是他性格的一部分。
There's also something funny about the way that the women respond, which is very childlike, like, oh my God, yeah, it's weirdly effective.
女主角们的反应也很有趣，她们表现得像个孩子一样，比如，“噢，天哪，太棒了”，这招产生奇效，简直不可思议。
I loved the bit when Barney comes over to take Marshall out, and he's like hand over the magic, you know, just pulling everything out.
我特别喜欢那个桥段：巴尼来找马修出去，然后他说把魔术交出来，你知道的，就是把所有东西都掏出来。
in the, yeah.
在那个，对。
So much fun and what's behind my ear?
太好玩了，“我耳后是什么？”
There's not that much.
其实没多少东西。
Yeah, that was such a good one.
对，那个真的太棒了。
And the Euro jerk, Euro jerk one, where he's almost got, he's almost written the correct thing on his hand.
还有那个欧洲混蛋，欧洲混蛋的那个梗，他差点，他差点在手上写对了东西。
That was really, yeah.
那个真的很，对。
I loved, you know, Ted's Penny thing.
我特别喜欢，你知道的，泰德的“便士”那个梗。
Was this the first, like, Ted loves old coins bit we had?
这是我们第一次出现类似“泰德喜欢老硬币”的桥段吗？
Yeah, I think this was, I think this was planting the seed of the coins.
对，我觉得这是，我觉得这是为硬币的梗埋下伏笔。
And then later we do an episode called Bucky Penny.
然后后来我们拍了一集叫《巴基·便士》。
And then later, and this isn't too much of the spoiler, he names his daughter Penny.
再后来——这也不算太剧透——他给自己的女儿起名叫便士。
Oh, right, right.
哦，对，对。
I loved, it's a real quick throw away.
我很喜欢，这是一个非常快的一带而过的笑点。
Just imagine the history this little guy's seen.
“想象一下这个小家伙见证过多少历史。”
I don't tell you, for me, the biggest laugh in the episode, for some reason, was after Robin jumps in to not tell Marshall about Lily and says, you know, Ted found an old penny or whatever, and the way Jason just went, way to go.
我跟你说，对我而言，这一集里最大的笑点，不知道为什么，就是罗宾插话进来不让马修知道莉莉的事，然后说，你知道的，泰德找到了一枚旧便士之类的，接着杰森随口说了一句“干得漂亮”。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
对，对，对。
like real sincere, like he knows what that means to Ted.
就显得特别真诚，好像他很清楚这对泰德意味着什么。
He knows that needs that.
他知道泰德需要这个。
He knows Ted needs that.
他知道泰德需要这种肯定。
He needs to feel it's important.
他需要觉得这件事很重要。
Yeah.
对。
And he just, he drops his whole drama that's going on.
然后他立刻放下了自己身上正在经历的所有抓马。
And she's like, I'm proud of you.
她就像是在说，我为你感到骄傲。
Some of my favorite laughs in How I Met Your Mother are not like, they're not like jokes you could even analyze why they're funny.
《老爸老妈浪漫史》里我最喜欢的一些笑点其实并不是，它们甚至不是那种你能分析出为什么好笑的笑点。
It's not a joke.
那根本不是个笑话。
这不是个笑话。
It's not a joke.
It's, yeah, it's, it's an attitude.
这，对，这是一种态度。
It's just a character revealing, kind of like Lily's thing.
这只是在展现角色，有点像莉莉的那种感觉。
It was a button, you know, that thing in the last episode.
那是个包袱，你知道的，就是上一集里的那个。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's not a joke.
对，对，对，这不是个笑话。
I don't know why that delighted me, but there's certain little things you guys were always finding for us to kind of like just be a little more emotionally or a little more teddy, you know?
我不知道为什么那让我很高兴，但你们总能为我们找出一些特定的小细节，让我们在情感上或者说在泰迪的特质上更丰富一点，你知道吗？
That's us feeling your guys' energies out as actors and as who you are as people and going, that would sound, that would be funny coming from Josh.
那是我们在作为演员摸索你们的能量，以及了解你们作为真实的自己是什么样的人，然后觉得，这话从乔斯嘴里说出来会很搞笑。
I would be funny, come for Jason, Jason's just turning, turning on a dime or on a penny, should I say, and being like, hey, great work, buddy.
由杰森来演会很搞笑，杰森说变就变，或者说一分钱难倒英雄汉，我是说，他就转变得像一分钱那么快，然后说，嘿，干得好，老兄。
And like, you realize that he knows Ted so well, he knows Ted needs that to be taken seriously, and Robin's not taking it seriously.
而且，你意识到他太了解泰德了，他知道泰德需要把这件事当真，而罗宾却没当真。
So Marshall's like, I'm gonna validate you for this penny thing.
所以马修就像是在说，我要为你的这个硬币梗给你认可。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
It's interesting that in the first season, remember I said that Lily and Marshall were like Ted's parents, we talked about they were his parents social cheerleaders.
有趣的是，在第一季里，还记得我说过莉莉和马修就像泰德的父母吗，我们聊过他们就像是泰德的社交啦啦队长。
And for the first couple of episodes of this season, it really gets flipped where Robin and Ted play that role for like heartbroken Marshall and then they start counseling Lilly.
而在这个季度的前几集里，这种情况真的反转了，罗宾和泰德开始扮演这个角色去照顾心碎的马修，然后他们开始开导莉莉。
Like they're the stable short-term but long-term couple.
就像他们成了短期但长期来看很稳定的情侣。
They really assume that role.
他们确实承担起了那个角色。
That's really smart.
这真的很聪明。
I don't know how conscious we were that we were doing that, but it's sort of me.
我不知道我们当时有多清醒地意识到我们在这样做，但这其实挺……
There was like a conservation of couplehood.
有点像情侣身份的守恒。
The couple transferred, but it kept that kind of rock or that anchor of the couple that can kind of care take for the crazy people flying around out in the insanity of the singleness in New York City.
情侣关系转移了，但它保留了那种基石或锚点的作用，能够照顾那些在纽约市单身生活的疯狂世界里到处乱飞的疯子们。
You're right.
你说得对。
Ted and Robin now have occupied that in this moment.
泰德和罗宾现在在这个时刻扮演了这个角色。
It's also, I think we talked about this in season one, but there's something about when you're in groups of friends, it's triage.
这也是，我想我们在第一季里讨论过，但当你们是一群朋友时，这就有点像分诊急救。
The energy has to go to the person who's bleeding out.
能量必须分配给那个正在大出血的人。
You know and Marshall's like bleeding out and so so Ted and Robin like Even naturally without writers playing like playing God have to take like a they they have to be the B.
你知道的，马修就像是在大出血，所以泰德和罗宾，甚至不需要编剧们像上帝之手那样刻意安排，就很自然地必须去承担——他们必须成为那个稳重的人。
C.
C.C.
Story Or they have to be supporting actors in the grand or drama because he's the one going through the insane and then Lily's the one going through it You know, yeah, yeah, it's true Ted and Tom Ted and Robin are now playing as a team.
或者他们必须成为宏大戏剧中的配角，因为他是经历疯狂的那个人，然后莉莉也是经历疯狂的人，你知道的，对，没错，这是真的，泰德和罗宾现在开始组队了。
Yeah, they're they're they're they're they're they're stories in these first couple of episodes are largely as a team now and it's different.
是的，在前几集里，他们俩的故事基本上都是以团队形式展开的，这感觉很不一样。
I also found it really nice to see Robin and Ted in like non-dramatic kind of early relationship bliss.
我也觉得看到罗宾和泰德处于那种没有戏剧冲突的早期恋爱幸福状态中，真的很美好。
Yeah, me too.
是的，我也是。
I'd forgotten that there's a lot of episodes where they're just together, you know, they're together in a really relaxed way.
我都忘了有很多集里他们就是在一起，你知道的，以一种非常放松的方式在一起。
There's not drama.
没有什么狗血剧情。
You don't see anyone's like avoidance or anxiety flaring up.
你不会看到任何人的逃避或焦虑情绪发作。
They're just like, they're in the gang, they're still in the gang, but they're together.
他们就像是在帮派里，他们依然在帮派里，但他们在一起了。
I thought it was very, there was something very pleasant about it.
我觉得这非常……其中有一种非常惬意的感觉。
And even when they're kind of a little bit at odds in this episode, meaning Robin has one take on Lily.
甚至当他们在这一集里有点意见不合时，意思是罗宾对莉莉有某种看法。
Robin's believing Lily's version of the story.
罗宾相信了莉莉版本的说辞。
And Ted is saying, I know her longer and better than you.
而泰德说，我认识她比你更久，也更了解她。
She's miserable.
她现在很痛苦。
And I will say, I really love, I love that Ted as such a good friend to Marshall is like, I kind of need her to be miserable, even though I love Lily too, I need her to be a little miserable for Marshall.
而且我要说，我真的很喜欢，我喜欢泰德作为马修的好朋友，那种态度就像是，我有点需要她过得痛苦，虽然我也很爱莉莉，但为了马修，我需要她稍微痛苦一点。
And Ted's right.
泰德是对的。
And it's very funny the scene with the $5 changing hands when the tequila kind of finally hits.
当龙舌兰酒的后劲终于上来时，五美元易手的那个场景非常搞笑。
Yeah.
是的。
And Lily and Alison crying and saying, the apartment is a metaphor for Marshall.
还有莉莉和艾莉森哭着说，公寓是马修的隐喻。
That's another great lie.
又一个绝妙的谎言。
The apartment is a metaphor for Marshall.
公寓是马修的隐喻。
That's such a weird thing to say while crying.
哭着的时候说出这种话真是太诡异了。
But just the delight, you played that great, I thought, because you're so happy you won the $5, but it doesn't feel mean.
但那种喜悦感，我觉得你演得太棒了，因为你赢了五美元太高兴了，但这并不让人觉得刻薄。
Right.
没错。
You're happy you won the $5.
你只是为赢了五美元感到高兴。
You're happy she's miserable, because her being miserable means she still loves Marshall, and they're going to get back together.
你很高兴她过得痛苦，因为她痛苦意味着她还爱着马歇尔，他们会复合的。
Ted wants them back together and he, but, but Ted is taking clean in a person crying, but in kind of the nicest, the best possible way.
泰德希望他们复合，而他，但是泰德是在欣赏一个人哭泣，不过是以一种最友善、最美好的方式。
It's a funny moment.
这是一个有趣的时刻。
My parents have this thing that I guess they've been doing for years, but my dad just said, well, your mom owes me $1.3 million.
我父母有这么个习惯，我想他们已经这样很多年了，但我爸刚说，你妈欠我130万美元。
And they apparently will bet over things like stupid things, but they do $100,000 best.
他们显然会为一些愚蠢的事情打赌，但他们一赌就是10万美元。
So the tally is she's up to 1.3 that she owes him, which I'm sure he's going to try to collect.
所以账面上她已经欠了他135万，我敢说他肯定会想办法去收账。
Yeah, he's going to collect it.
对，他会去收账的。
Yeah.
对。
But I like that Ted was rooting for her misery in a way that I think is fundamentally sweet and that's why it worked.
但我喜欢泰德幸灾乐祸的样子，我觉得这基本上是很可爱的，所以这招才管用。
He wants her to miss his best friend and she's also kind of his best friend.
他希望她想念他最好的朋友，而她某种程度上也是他最好的朋友。
And if she's miserable, it means she's going to come back and they'll get to put this whole thing back together or maybe not right away.
如果她过得痛苦，就意味着她会回来，他们就能重修旧好，或者也许不会马上复合。
And that was, I love that that was Ted's motivation.
而我喜欢的是，这就是泰德的动机。
And it, but that's why I felt very okay laughing at Ted taking cleanly having breakdown.
而且，这就是为什么我觉得看泰德津津有味地看着别人崩溃，笑得毫无心理负担。
And Robin was wrong.
罗宾也错了。
Robin Ted did know Lily better than he knew.
罗宾，泰德确实比她更了解莉莉。
He just knew he knew it was for that.
他只是知道，他知道这是为了……
Cinco De Mayo 1998, Lily.
1998年五月五日节，莉莉。
He has a lot of history with her.
他和她有着很深的过去。
I'm not cleaning that up again.
我才不重新收拾那个呢。
I thought the scene in the taxi with them where Barney throws the number out the window and then Marshall gets out of the car to chase it down and you realize he's just slitted into this.
我觉得出租车里他们俩的那场戏里，巴尼把号码扔出窗外，然后马歇尔下车去追，你意识到他只是落入了圈套。
More magic.
更多的魔法。
It's just more magic.
这简直是更多的魔法。
In search of revealing his scorpion nature.
旨在暴露他蝎子的本性。
Yeah, absolutely.
对，绝对是的。
I love when they fight, they're fighting in there, I think.
我喜欢他们打架的时候，他们在里面打架，我觉得。
And Marshall says, I'll kill you.
马歇尔说，我要杀了你。
Yeah.
对。
It's such a funny, like visceral thing.
这真是一个搞笑且发自肺腑的桥段。
I was watching that with my wife and she was like, cracked up at that moment.
我当时和我妻子一起看，她在那一刻笑翻了。
She's like, I like the simplicity of I'll kill you.
她说，我喜欢“我要杀了你”这种简单粗暴。
When he says I'm gonna take this one too.
当他说“这个我也要拿走”的时候。
It's such a funny line that we put to them.
这是我们想出来的超搞笑的台词。
And it's almost literally Homer Simpson strangling Bart.
这几乎就是字面意思上的荷马·辛普森掐巴特。
Like it's literally the same thing.
就像字面上的同一个场景。
It really is, I'll kill you.
真的是这样，我要杀了你。
Oh my God.
哦，天哪。
Going back to the Barney and Marshall storyline, I thought you guys were really walking a very fine line because Barney is deeply shitty in this episode.
回到巴尼和马歇尔的故事线，我觉得你们真的是在走钢丝，因为巴尼在这集里简直混蛋透顶。
He's so terrible.
他太糟糕了。
Really bad.
真的很过分。
And especially like sweet, vulnerable, Marshall, like doing his best to like pick himself up and get out there.
尤其是那种温柔、脆弱的马歇尔，尽最大努力振作起来并重新融入社交。
Fucking brutal.
简直太残忍了。
It's brutal, you know?
太残忍了，你知道吗？
It really is.
真的是这样。
That's why I think the whole episode only works because of how great and funny that come up in Swaz at the end.
这就是为什么我觉得整集能成立，完全是因为最后斯威茨（Swaz）想出的那个绝妙又搞笑的点子。
Yes.
没错。
And that it's Marshall's idea that literally helps him with, and Barney at the end has to admit that it was well-played.
而且这完全是马歇尔的主意，字面意义上帮了他，巴尼最后也不得不承认这招玩得漂亮。
Yes.
没错。
And that, I don't think the whole episode would not have worked had that ending not landed, I think.
而且，我觉得如果没有那个精彩的结尾，整集是绝对不会成功的。
One of my favorite though, the line that did make me laugh from Barney is, they're not the same person.
不过我最喜欢的台词之一，让我笑出声的巴尼的台词是，他们不是同一个人。
No, identical, identical, same, nickel, nickel person.
不，一模一样，一模一样，简直一个模子刻出来的。
So fucking weird.
太他妈诡异了。
Remember that, I think we might have talked about this, but Adam McKay who worked with Will Ferrell on so many classic movies, like he used to say there's nothing funnier people being confidently wrong.
还记得吗，我想我们可能讨论过这个，亚当·麦凯曾和威尔·法瑞尔合作过许多经典电影，他以前常说，没有什么比人盲目自信地犯错更搞笑的了。
And Barney is just such a fount of confident wrongness.
而巴尼就是一个自信地犯错的源泉。
He's the most confident about the things he's wrongest about, which is very much how a lot of our modern male culture is.
他对那些错得最离谱的事情反而最自信，这非常符合我们许多现代男性文化。
And at this moment, I am in 2025.
而此刻，我身处2025年。
Barney is a bit of a precursor to Trump.
巴尼有点像是特朗普的先驱。
He's a precursor in terms of the You know, just the amount of stuff that comes out of him, and also the certainty with which he cites facts and figures, or he thinks that everything he says is like, no, this is correct.
他在某种程度上是个先驱，你知道的，就是他嘴里吐出的那些话的体量，还有他引用事实和数据时的确信语气，或者他认为自己说的每件事都像是在说，不，这绝对是对的。
The insistence that he is correct, it was a little ahead of the moment, I think.
这种坚信自己绝对正确的态度，我觉得有点超前于那个时代了。
Yeah, I mean, yeah, I think we are teasing out something about like toxic masculinity and Barney.
对，我的意思是，是的，我觉得我们正在探讨关于巴尼身上的有毒男子气概的一些东西。
And of course, we always try to show, not in this one, not in this episode, but a lot of other gems we showed the beating heart and a scarves beneath that.
当然，我们总是试图展现——不是在这集里，不是这一集，而是在其他很多精彩剧集中，我们展现了那厚重外表下跳动的心脏和伤疤。
And that's what's interesting.
这就是有趣的地方。
I think about Barney.
我认为关于巴尼。
That's why he's lovable.
这就是他讨人喜欢的原因。
And yeah, I think that idea of you're kind of creating this product version of yourself.
是的，我觉得那种你正在打造一个“产品版”自己的想法。
That's a bit chumpy, right?
这有点像个骗局，对吧？
That's a bit like modern male, kind of like Manosphere.
这有点像现代男性，有点像“男权社群”（Manosphere）那一套。
He's a brand.
他是一个品牌。
Yeah, like he's a bit of you're making yourself as a brand, right?
对，就像你把自己当成一个品牌来打造，对吧？
It's that idea.
就是那种概念。
And that predates Trump and that will, that will, something like that will always exist.
这比特朗普出现得更早，而且这种现象，类似的东西将永远存在。
But Barney, Barney's definitely doing that.
但巴尼，巴尼绝对在这么做。
He even says, the peeps need much tweets later.
他甚至说过，“粉丝们以后会发很多推特的”。
He makes me much tweets.
他让我发很多推特。
He knows, yeah, like Barney could have written something called The Art of the Deal.
他懂的，对啊，就像巴尼完全写得出《交易的艺术》这种书。
You know, Barney has the playbook, you know what I mean?
你知道的，巴尼有他自己的一套行事手册，你知道我的意思吧？
There are overlaps.
这里面有重合之处。
I will hasten to point out that I really enjoy how much we see why Barney is the way he is and how over the course of the show, we see him change and evolve.
我得赶快指出，我真的很喜欢我们能看到为什么巴尼会变成这样，以及随着剧集的推进，我们看到他的改变和进化。
And you see a side of him that is very much not for show in this episode.
在这集中，你看到了他很不为人知、绝非作秀的一面。
This is kind of the darkest worst part of Barney in this episode.
这可以说是巴尼在这集里最黑暗、最糟糕的一面。
But I think we start to see, and I'm sure that if you peel about the layers on anybody who puts up that much bravado, you can find the humanity underneath it.
但我认为我们开始看到，而且我确信，如果你剥开任何一个表现得如此虚张声势的人的外壳，你都能在底下找到他的人性。
I, that was our goal with Barney.
我，这就是我们对巴尼的目标。
But in this episode, we really didn't do that at all.
但在这一集里，我们真的完全没有这么做。
We just kind of, we just had him be shitty in this one.
我们只是，我们只是让他在这集里表现得很混蛋。
And it was funny.
而且这确实很搞笑。
And at the end, he kind of, he tries to slightly justify it by saying, I'm just teaching you what it's like out here, kid.
到了最后，他有点试图通过说“我只是在教你外面的世界是什么样的，孩子”来稍微为自己辩解。
And it was just like, kind of not true.
这感觉就有点名不副实。
It's like, maybe it's a little truth.
就像是，也许有一点点真相吧。
It's does he really believe that is the question.
问题是他自己真的相信这一点吗？
That's the philosophical debate of this episode.
这就是这一集的哲学辩论。
Does Barney think he's in any way actually helping Marshall or is he just absolutely being a sociopath?
巴尼觉得自己有在任何方面真正帮到马歇尔吗？还是他纯粹是在当一个反社会人格者？
Well, it's also, it's like proper addiction.
嗯，这也是，这就好比真正的毒瘾。
Like addiction will, you will betray your family.
毒瘾会让你背叛家庭。
Like you will rob your family.
就像你会抢劫你的家人一样。
Yes, it makes you compromise any sort of value system you might have, so.
是的，它会让你妥协你可能拥有的任何价值体系，所以。
You're right, it's an addiction narrative.
你说得对，这是一个关于毒瘾的故事。
That's what this one was.
这一集讲的就是这个。
It really is Barney can't stop, he needs help.
真的是巴尼停不下来，他需要帮助。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
Well, I think it's very brave.
嗯，我觉得这非常勇敢。
Do you know what we didn't think of the interventions until later on in this series?
你知道吗，直到这季节目的后期，我们才想到干预措施？
It was brave of you guys to, you know, you talk about him as a cartoon, but like it was brave of you guys to like go to the outer limits of like how horrible he could be.
你们真的很勇敢，你知道的，虽然你们把他当成卡通人物来谈论，但你们敢于探讨他到底能有多坏，去触及那些极端边缘。
I was impressed and a little like, wow.
我印象深刻，甚至有点“哇”的感觉。
I forgot how dark we went with Barney in this one.
我都忘了我们在这一集里把巴尼写得这么黑暗。
He is the scorpion.
他就是那只蝎子。
He's the scorpion.
Yeah.
是的。
All right, this week, instead of some general questions.
好了，这周我们不回答一些常规问题。
General questions.
常规问题。
that we're not doing.
我们不做的那些。
That's perfect though.
不过那也挺完美的。
We should do that one more.
我们应该再多做一次那个。
That was pretty simple.
那个挺简单的。
Just a couple of quick comments from general comments from the internet.
只有来自网上的几条简短评论。
Tanner Riffesam, sorry.
坦纳·里夫萨姆，抱歉。
Says, thank God you're coming back.
说，谢天谢地你们回来了。
You guys always make the drive to work and the Atlanta traffic a little more bearable.
你们总是让开车上班和亚特兰大的交通变得没那么难以忍受。
Xavier Roberto 87 says, dude, this podcast is so funny.
泽维尔·罗伯托87说，老兄，这个播客太搞笑了。
And Samia Bianchi says, Oh my God, I can't believe this podcast exists.
萨米娅·比安奇说，天哪，我真不敢相信这个播客居然存在。
That can go either way.
这句话可以有两层意思。
You know, that can be good or bad.
你知道的，这可能是好事也可能是坏事。
I suppose so.
我想也是。
I can't believe this podcast exists.
我真不敢相信这个播客居然存在。
I can machine might hate it.
AI机器可能会讨厌它。
I suppose there are emojis, but I'm 50.
我想那里有表情符号，但我已经50岁了。
So I don't, I can't find what they are, their faces of things.
所以我找不到它们是什么，那些各种表情的脸。
I also can't see them.
我也看不清它们。
It's just eggplants.
全都是茄子。
That's my glasses.
那是我的眼镜。
Yes.
是的。
And Miss Channick teaches us for the Scorpion and the Toad.
还有查尼克小姐教我们关于蝎子和青蛙的故事。
Did you know that the German title for this episode translates to new life, old mistakes.
你知道这一集的德语剧名翻译过来是“新生活，旧错误”吗？
Wow, really?
真的吗？
I didn't realize there were like titles that were like that far off of what the literal and that's amazing.
我没想到有些剧名会和字面意思差那么多，这太神奇了。
Anybody else out there listening that can you please share what the titles are in your country?
外面还有其他听众吗？能请大家分享一下你们国家的剧名是什么吗？
Because I need fun translations.
因为我需要有趣的翻译。
I could hear those all day long.
我听一整天都听不腻。
That's amazing.
这太棒了。
And Craig, talk to us.
克雷格，跟我们聊聊吧。
You've got something really amazing to tell us about.
你有什么非常棒的事情要告诉我们。
Yeah, so when this episode of our podcast drops and you're listening to this right now, if you're listening to it, October 27th, that week.
好的，当我们的播客这一集上线，你现在正在收听时，如果你是在10月27日那一周收听的话。
Now, the week after this one, you're here that you're listening to now.
现在，也就是你现在听的这一周之后的那个星期。
November 4th, my debut novel comes out.
11月4日，我的处女作小说就要出版了。
It's called, That's Not How It Happened for sale wherever you buy books, where you can go to my website, cragcomiswriter.com slash novel.
书名叫《事情可不是这样的》，在各大书店均有售，或者你也可以访问我的网站 cragcomiswriter.com/novel。
And there's just a bunch of different ways to buy the actual physical book and the audio book.
上面有很多不同的途径可以买到实体书和有声书。
This book is told through four different perspectives, and so there's four different audiobook narrators, and two of them are Josh Wagner and Kobe Smalters, which is like an absolutely dream come true for me to have you guys come in and like add to that project.
这本书通过四个不同的视角来讲述，所以有四个不同的有声书旁白，其中两个是乔什·瓦格纳和科比·史墨德斯，对我来说，能让你们加入并为这个项目增添光彩，简直就像梦想成真一样。
This book means the world to me.
这本书对我意义重大。
It's my favorite thing I've ever written besides how I met your mother.
除了《老爸老妈浪漫史》之外，它是我写过的最喜欢的东西。
And it's based on a part of my life.
它基于我生活中的一部分。
I didn't really get to explore in how I met your mother.
那是我在《老爸老妈浪漫史》中没有真正深入探讨过的部分。
My wife and I, our son, has disabilities, both learning disabilities and some health challenges.
我和我妻子，我们的儿子有残疾，包括学习障碍和一些健康挑战。
And I wrote about a family that's in that situation.
我写了一个处于那种处境中的家庭。
It's a comedy.
这是一部喜剧。
It's a comedy about the complexity of a family where one of the kids, in this case, has Down syndrome and has had open heart surgery.
这是一部关于家庭复杂性的喜剧，其中一个孩子，在这个故事里，患有唐氏综合征并做过心脏开胸手术。
And we're seeing all of the family's perspective on what it's like to be a family in that situation.
我们从全家人的视角，来看待身处那种境况中的家庭生活是怎样的。
And it is very much a comedy.
它确实是一部喜剧。
It's full of heart.
它充满了温情。
It's full of jokes.
它充满了笑料。
And I try to also dig into the reality of what's going on in that family.
我也试图深入探讨这个家庭中所发生事情的现实情况。
And I'm so honored that Josh and Kobe are lending their voices to this.
我非常荣幸乔什和科比能为这个项目献声。
I think how much I'm under fans will really like it.
我想《老爸老妈浪漫史》的粉丝们一定会非常喜欢它。
It's told in a structurally playful way, kind of like how much I'm under jumps around perspectives and time and stuff.
它的结构很有巧思，有点像《老爸老妈浪漫史》那样在视角和时间上跳来跳去。
And there's a lot of playful storytelling in it.
里面有很多充满趣味的叙事手法。
I hope him fans will check it out.
我希望《老爸老妈浪漫史》的粉丝们能去看看。
So I just want to do a little plug for that.
所以我只是想为它打个小小的广告。
Can I just offer a little something in addition to that?
我能顺便补充一点小东西吗？
I have a book coming, no, it's not.
我有一本书要出，不，其实没有。
And it's better than Craig's book.
而且它比克雷格的书还要好。
Yeah.
是的。
So I read the father, Rob, which was delightful.
所以我读了爸爸罗布的部分，非常精彩。
But I did read the whole book.
不过我确实读了整本书。
I didn't just read the Rob section before.
我之前不只是读了罗布的部分。
Yes, so I wanted to know the context.
是的，所以我想了解来龙去脉。
But I was delighted by this book.
但我对这本书爱不释手。
It is super page turning.
它超级引人入胜。
It is like breathlessly and hilariously plotted.
它的情节设计令人窒息又滑稽爆笑。
But also, I told Craig I've never read a novel where the interiority was just as rich and as fun as the plot twists.
而且，我告诉过克雷格，我从未读过哪部小说的内心独白能像情节反转那样丰富有趣。
And I think that his many years of crafting great narratives on television, you know, it came to bear on this.
我想他在电视上创作伟大叙事的多年经验，你知道的，在这上面发挥了作用。
But also like your gifts as a novelist are just abundant.
但同时你作为小说家的天赋也是极其丰厚的。
And I really, I mean, I kept telling my wife how much I was enjoying reading this book.
真的，我是说，我一直在向我妻子表达我有多么享受阅读这本书。
It didn't take me that long.
我没花多少时间就读完了。
It's a quick read.
这是一本读起来很快的书。
But I was so delighted by it.
但我对它爱不释手。
It's incredibly vivid.
它极其生动。
You're really seeing it as you read it.
你在阅读的时候脑海中就能清晰地浮现出画面。
And I just thought there's so many pleasures to be having this novel.
我只是觉得在这本小说里能获得太多的乐趣。
And I, even if you were my mortal enemy, I would be forced to, I'd love you dearly.
而且，就算你是我的死敌，我也会被迫——我其实非常爱你，你是我的挚友之一。
You're one of my best friends.
你是我最好的朋友之一。
but I would be forced to concede that you had written a great book.
但我还是会不得不承认你写了一本好书。
Well, that is amazing.
嗯，这太棒了。
I wish that could be a blurb on the book, even if Frank Thomas is my mortal enemy.
我真希望这能成为书上的名人推荐语，哪怕弗兰克·托马斯是我的死敌。
Which he's not, but you will not be disappointed if you pick up this book or listen to this book.
当然他不是，但如果你拿起这本书或听这本书，你绝不会失望。
So check it out.
所以去看看吧。
That means the world to me and I would be honored.
这对我意义重大，我将深感荣幸。
I'm honored you and Kobe are part of it and the audiobook and I would be honored if how much I'm under fans would give it a read.
我很荣幸你和科比能参与有声书的录制，如果《老爸老妈浪漫史》的粉丝们能读一读这本书，我将不胜荣幸。
And finally, Josh, we have a great story take us out today from from a fan.
最后，乔什，我们今天有一位粉丝发来的精彩故事来为节目收尾。
Here is a terrific letter from one of our listeners.
这里有一封来自我们听众的超级棒的信。
I'm so excited for the continuation of the show.
我太兴奋了，节目还要继续。
Whimmyam has been such a fantastic dive and I'm really enjoying the chance to think more deeply about hymnium with y'all.
Whimmyam 是一次非常棒的深入探讨，我真的很享受能有机会和大家一起更深入地思考赞美诗。
Like most of those listening to the show, I've always thought about hymnium beyond the surface level and this has been such a validating listen.
就像听节目的大多数人一样，我一直都在超越表层去思考赞美诗，这次的收听让我深感共鸣。
When it comes to season two my thoughts go straight to Lily.
说到第二季，我的脑海里立刻浮现出莉莉。
She takes a massive risk by leaving the safety of Marshall to pursue her art, but when she returns, it is on her own terms, ready to take the leap into the next stage of life and ready to face the consequences of her choices.
她冒着巨大的风险离开安全区马歇尔去追求艺术，但当她归来时，她是带着自己的条件回来的，准备好跨入人生的下一个阶段，并准备好承担自己选择的后果。
Her character captures both the doubt and strength of the creative mind.
她的角色既捕捉到了创作心灵的迷茫，也捕捉到了它的力量。
She is so brave, and I truly admire her for her risk.
她非常勇敢，我真的很佩服她敢于冒险的精神。
The more I've rewatched the show over the years, the more I find myself relating to her, especially in later seasons.
这些年来，随着我一遍又一遍地重温这部剧，我发现自己越来越能与她产生共鸣，尤其是在后几季中。
Like Lily, I've always had creative pursuits that that often get pushed aside for, quote, real life.
和莉莉一样，我一直都有自己的艺术追求，但这些追求往往为了所谓的“现实生活”而被搁置一旁。
And her story has reminded me not to delay the goals I want to accomplish, and that keeps me pushing forward.
她的故事提醒我不要延迟实现自己想要的目标，这让我不断向前迈进。
Chasing my silly art dream is what Lily would want.
追求我那些傻气的艺术梦想正是莉莉希望看到的。
Thanks for keeping this show magical, Amanda.
阿曼达，谢谢你让这个节目保持魔力。
Oh man, I love that.
天哪，我太喜欢这个了。
Amanda, I don't want to give notes on your lovely, lovely letter, but I don't think your art dream is silly.
阿曼达，我不想对你这封可爱至极的信提出修改意见，但我认为你的艺术梦想一点也不傻气。
Yeah, yeah, well said.
对，对，说得好。
That's a good note.
这是一个很好的意见。
You can drop that modifier.
你可以把那个修饰词去掉。
There's such a thing as a good note, and that's a good note, and Josh is right, and I'm so glad that you related to Lillian, it helped you feel like, pursuing your very not silly goals, so well done.
意见也是分好坏的，这是一个好意见，乔什说得对，我很高兴你能对莉莉安产生共鸣，这让你觉得在追求那些绝不傻气的目标，所以做得好。
How We Made Your Mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas, and is presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
《How We Made Your Mother》由乔什·拉德纳（Josh Radner）和克雷格·托马斯（Craig Thomas）主持并担任执行制片人，由 Office Ladies Network 和 Odyssey 呈现与分发。
Odyssey.
Odyssey。
This episode is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
本集的执行制片人还有珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fisher）和安吉拉·金赛（Angela Kinsey）。
The show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
本节目由我亚历克·莱夫（Alec Lev）制作和剪辑，我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡（Doug Matica）。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios.
我们的音频制片人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的亚历克斯·里夫斯（Alex Reeves）。
Our digital content producer aka Gen Z Master is Emily Blumberg.
我们的数字内容制作人，即 Z 世代大师是艾米莉·布隆伯格（Emily Blumberg）。
Artwork by John Morrow.
封面插图由约翰·莫罗（John Morrow）绘制。
Please follow, rate and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在苹果播客或你选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论本节目。
really does help the show.
这确实对节目很有帮助。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是《New York City》，由我们自己的乔什·拉德纳创作，克雷格·托马斯和安德鲁·马朱斯基（Andrew Majuski）提供额外音乐。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢萝拉·肯尼迪（Lola Kennedy）和埃利奥特·康纳斯（Elliot Connors）。
Visit HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，并点击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
你们的故事和问题是本节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at Josh Order Craig Thomas' debut novel, that's not how it happened, wherever books are sold, and check out his other published writings at CraigThomasWriter.com.
请在 Substack 上订阅乔什·拉德纳的简讯，并在 Josh 处查看他的音乐及其他内容，在各大书店购买克雷格·托马斯的长篇小说处女作《That's Not How It Happened》，并在 CraigThomasWriter.com 上查看他的其他发表作品。
And you can subscribe to my own Dead Fathers Society, also on Substack.
你也可以订阅我自己的《Dead Fathers Society》，同样在 Substack 上。
To learn more about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign, to raise money for congenital pediatric heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解更多关于如何做出改变的信息——本节目旨在为先天性小儿心脏病研究筹集资金的长期活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”标签页。
will, in fact, dance.
事实上，我会跳舞。